hi oh yeah got involved if you want me
to drive you we got to go now personal
chauffeur go horse okay
seriously dad walking would have been
fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day
against spider-man this guy swings in
once the day's zip zap zop dancing you
get arrested gosh don't cops run red
lights oh yeah some do but uh not your
dad in your universe there's only one
spider-man but there's another universe
it looks it sounds like yours but it's
not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you like me come around his
time I know it's complicated I don't
know what happened to you I can teach
you to be spider-man I love this photo
lucious the best burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about saving
the world you have to think about saving
one person one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
just see the sparking it's amazing
airdrop whatever you choose to do with
it you'll be great
I love you mom's no dad you gotta say I
love you back how do you serious I want
to hear it you want to hear my dad I
love you got a copy time to swing just
like I thought when did you teach me
that I didn't it's a little joke the
team-building hey guys okay who are you
I'm Gwen Stacy my people are there
senator comic-con what's Co
[Applause]
[Music]
this morning I woke up in
[Applause]
wait so how many of us are you
you